uh so it's really a pleasure to be here
to attend the inauguration of this new
uh integrative computational
NeuroScience Center of course MIT is a
special place in this field I thought I
would mention uh that uh Noble winner
you know pioneered What's called the
cybernetics here at MIT and this year is
also the
40th anniversary of the publication by
David Marr the book called Vision which
is still very much influencing
neuroscience and cognitive science
um if you're familiar with Debbie Moss
work you're probably mostly remember
especially younger people uh that he was
really a Pioneer uh you know in
computational cognitive science mostly
From computational perspective but maybe
it's good to mention that he has deep
roots in your own biology when he was
under a graduate student he published
this series of three papers really
seminar papers model theories of you
know hippocampus
cerebellum and neocortex based on
Anatomy based on the circuits
unfortunately he passed away at a young
age of 35
as Francis Creek who knew him you know
stated had he lived longer he would have
moved to a synthesis of those two
approaches so perhaps today we can
together start to think about how we can
help to realize that vision of a
sentences
um so of course today we are living in
in an era where AI provides all aspects
of society
um just to mention that um you know
although today's air systems
um are tremendously successful in
solving certain problems better than
humans
you could say that if it's purely fit
for the architecture then when there's
no external input the system is
essentially silent right it doesn't do
anything so in that sense you could say
that this type of systems don't really
have a mental life okay by contrast you
know thinking reasoning planning
somehow this went away
this
microphone stopped working
oh maybe Michael he did something
but but this this stuff not working
oh you want me to use this now yeah okay
oh great okay sure
that's good that solves the problem
either way good
yeah no this is great
[Laughter]
well I just hope that Robert will give
me five more minutes
um so I'm saying that you know reasoning
thinking planning right feeling
something from your found memory uh it's
actually internal processes that are
really not enslaved to the environment
and so those processes depend on some
brain structures especially What's
called the preformal cortex right so
maybe a challenge for us is to think
about building uh you know theory of you
know deep recurrent neural networks that
are capable of this more kind of
internally driven processes right
they're important for mental life so you
know if you try to think into the future
right what kind of uh you know measure
of success for such a model we could
think about I would just mention one
thing repeating what they just said
basically uh you know a machine right
with human-like intelligence should in
principle without any external
stimulation
um you know have something like you know
reasoning using logic uh maybe creating
something new uh and perhaps even
emotional feelings uh you know out of
memory so I'm going to tell you a bit
about how we start to think about this
type of internally driven processes uh
first a little bit of summary about the
micro circuits that we have been
thinking about uh and and then spend
more time as Robert mentioned our recent
work building multi-regional large-scale
models so we're going to pay attention
to connectomics anatomy and neuron
physiology and the biophysically based
models end up being known in a dynamical
systems let me just give you you know
for those of you who are not familiar
with what we do a very simple example
imagine that you are asked to make a
perceptual decision making
where you are shown a display of random
dots and your judgment is whether the
net motion of the the stimulus is uh you
know a upward or B downward all right so
you can think about as a little micro
circuit where you have uh neuron groups
or neural assemblies A or B within each
there are strong Recon excitation
between p and the cells and then the two
neuron groups compete against each other
so what's interesting about this type of
model I think is this Duality so on one
hand I don't know if you can actually do
have a pointer maybe I just use the
cursor
um as you see on the right on one hand
you see this uh very slow transient in
the form of Quasi linear ramping
activity up to a second which has been
shown in single neurophysiology to
underline accumulation of information
accumulation of evidence in favor
against the different options here A or
B and on the other hand there's also
categorical Choice by when I take all
competition done by attractive Dynamics
right in this model and the same
mechanism can sustain activity when the
stimulus is gone so you can hold in
working memory your choice for later use
right and also as I mentioned I'm very
happy to hear is that one big challenge
to understand the brain is cross-level
understanding right so this kind of
model you know try to you know move in
that direction so in this case starting
with recurrent Dynamics you can ask
what's the mechanism only buying slow
transients right it turns out in this
case it's NDA dependent Recon excitation
so this is something you can test right
using some drugs or you know
agonists uh you know antagonist on the
other hand you can go up right look at
the psychometric function to be compared
with behavioral measurements in the
experiments so this line of research has
led to the idea that you know although
the scheme looks like Universal right uh
you know it could be V1 model but but
somehow under certain conditions uh the
same kind of circuit can underline
cognitive kind of computations uh like
working I mean decision making so you
know over the last I don't know almost
two two decades now where I've been you
know we have been exploring different
kind of building blocks of cognition I
would say you know Robert Young's work
in his PhD really kind of represents
what where we are now so we ask the
question about how a local circuit in
PFC for example kind of lines so many
um you know tasks right so that way you
can start to ask questions uh like how
abstract task and representation really
is realized by neuron circuits
um I guess one of the open questions uh
you know in this line work is what is
the dynamical nature of internal States
underlying working memory and decision
making I just want to make a point uh
you know that when we say attractor
States we don't mean necessarily steady
States right so this those are two
examples where you can have stochastic
oscillations uh in your network right
that are attractive States maybe for
physicists even turbulence is actually
described as attractive state by Navid
Stokes equation right so those are very
complex spatial temporal patterns uh but
they are attractive States so but but
what is exactly the nature of spatial
temporal interactivity patterns that are
important for internal mental processes
is is not known right so that um you
know we try to start to think about that
but but the temporal aspect of the
things is really a very interesting are
still underexported Direction but for
the rest of the talk I would kind of
move on to the special aspect of uh you
know cognitive functions because we now
know and we become more and more aware
that even working memory of a simple
stimuli involves multiple brain regions
so this is a meta-analysis figure
showing around access different cortical
areas in Monkey How likely you would see
a delay activity in red uh you know in
individual
experimental studies
so it's not uniform right across all
cortical areas certain areas seem to be
engaged in working memory more
permanently than the others but but on
the other hand is also distributed right
and and also aramilla for example showed
that if your similarity recorded for
multiple brain regions in this case six
also code areas in Market monkey in a
simple decision task you also see very
distributed processes right so it's a
puzzle right how can we understand uh
distributed working memory in decision
making
so I would say it's timely to raise this
question because of the advances you
know of experimental tools and and the
measurements right so I'm going to tell
you a story from my lab where we
collaborated with Henry Kennedy
anatomist in in France who relatively
recently published a database of
inter-area connectivity in cortex so
basically and Skip some details but just
to tell you that they had a way to
assess directed and awaited the
connectivity between cortical areas if
you plot the statistics of the weights
in the upper right panel you'll see you
know five volts of magnitude range of
the weight values that fit with a log
normal distribution and also in the
lower right panel it's shown the weight
of a connection between two areas as
function of the distance between the two
right
plot meaning that the you know the
network is really specially embedding it
depends on special proximity between
areas not a pure topological graph as
you would you know describe with a graph
Theory
so imagine that you take this
connectivity Matrix to build a dynamical
model of many interacting uh you know
macaque codex areas by the way I also
should mention that there's a lot of
feedback projections about 65 of all
possible connections are present right
so it's kind of a tense connection at
this level of cortical cortical
connectivity so we did that so we
started with this connectivity Matrix
and the next question is what do you put
in in each local area right to build a
dynamical model so I'm going to give you
three versions how we went about doing
that right so the first version is to
start with this idea very influential
idea that there's a canonical circuit
that kind of repeats across the cortical
mantle even across species right in the
mamanian Kingdom
um so that's saying basically that all
cortical errors are the same what's
different is input output patterns right
okay how close you are to senses and how
they talk to each other right so that
definitely is true but but it's now the
only uh answer I think because we do
also have to think about
um on the other hand
um there's this idea of modular
organization right
um you know uh you know that's a
chemistry for example uh proposed that
and showed that for a certain type of
information processing for sure right
um and also maybe in the in the brain
right there's also some kind of
modularity and so we try to think about
how do you square right between one hand
a universal kind of canonical circuit uh
uh architecture on the other hand
there's this modularity of functions
um so we are going to take the view that
yes input patterns are important but
also what's a bit less uh emphasized is
that in fact quantitatively there are
variations from area to area right
heterogeneities if you like right so one
example would be you know do genomic
analysis you will see a lot of you know
Gene Expressions that are different from
error to area
um so we actually started by looking at
the older database which is just a spine
count as you know spines are the sides
of accessory synapses in pyramidal cells
and there's only one synapse per spine
so that's very nice you can think about
number of spines per neuron as a proxy
for the strengths of excitation putting
around and that turns out to change
quite a bit from ear to area as shown in
the lower left panel right as a function
of hierarchy so actually the change is
about 10 fold right from V1 all the way
to PFC and so this is one example of
what we call microscopical gradients
right so some biological properties that
change from area to area are not high
dimensional hydrogenities but they
somehow show this gradients in low
dimensional along those dimensional axis
right so if you're interested
you can take a look at another more
about especially the ones that are
important for excitation and inhibition
right which we know are functionally
important you know we are by this way of
thinking about it we actually found a
way to use genomic data which is still
rare in computational Neuroscience so
we're kind of excited by that
um you know in a way a big challenge is
how to relate from Gene to behavior
through circuits right so we start to
think about and that's especially
important if you care about psychiatric
disorders right in computational
Psychiatry just to mention that
in my mind this is a not only a way to
do it but also a way to do it for a
large-scale system
so Rishi who was a graduate student back
then built that Dynamic model basically
explained to you using the structured
data and I introduced this microscope
gradient uh for the dining room model
which is simply means for for modelers
that use exactly the same mathematical
equation for each local circuit but then
the strands of excitation is skilled by
a number that's proportional to the
spine count all right that's all right
and so and this is a simulation of the
resting state where each area is driven
by by noise right the network is not
doing anything and then we found you
know right away the the the the time
constant that dominates the Dynamics is
very different from area to area as
Quantified here by Auto Collision
function of the time series from each
area right and the shown on the lower
right the time the time constant for
like 14 areas as a function of hierarchy
right notice that the range is pretty
big from 20 milliseconds to more than
one second but it's not a monotonic as a
function of the hierarchy defined by
hierarchy right so this is really a
reflection of both microscopical
gradient or properties and this
complicated connectivity Matrix
properties
um this kind of hierarchy of time
constants is really I think very
interesting for a number of reasons to
start with you want early signs of areas
to be very fast in order to process a
quickly changing external stimuli on the
other hand when I talk about ramping
activity underlying accumulation of
information in decision making you have
very strong Slow Time constants right in
the underlying circuit so there is now
increasing evidence from single neuron
recordings that there is indeed a
hierarchy of time constants in a monkey
shown at the top and also mice just a
little bit lower left and as you know by
very different measure possibly
important also you know for human Say
speech understand it right it started
with very short time constants to
understand the words and then you
integrate words into phrases from phases
to sentences to narratives and there's
some evidence that that those different
you know Integrations involve uh
somewhat distant speech related brain
regions
um so the second version of the model we
did is to incorporate laminate structure
that's because as you know if you want
to understand top down versus bottom up
right volume up projection originates
from supervision layer and top-down
projections started with d players going
to lower areas and so in order to
compare our model with neurophysiology
we focused on physiological Studies by
our Miller Pascal fries and others
showing basically that the you know
fitfall processing seem to enhance gamma
oscillation related coherence was top
down enhances synchrony in alpha or low
beta frequency range so I'm going to
skip the details of this work just to
show that you know uh and and that
you know actually led us to learn a
number of things
um I want to end this part just by
showing a suggested schema from this
work which could be relevant to predict
the coding
um so this is coming derived from that
study as you know preview coding idea
says that our brain is not passive right
we constantly try to
infer or predict what's going to happen
next in the environment so that seemed
to imply some kind of comparison between
expectation why and reality x something
like x minus y right okay there may be
several ways of doing that but what we
found a possible substrate for this is
is shown at the bottom so basically if
the top down y signal the expectation
signal uh you know goes to the Deep
layer which projects to the inhibitor
neurons in the supervision layer then
change the sign from y to minus y right
and so that can be compared with X right
we are starting to explore you know this
type of circuit for
predicted coding now um
so how about the working memory so this
is my third kind of version of the model
right now so now each local circuit is a
full-fledged non-linear
multi-attractor Network actually the
same model I described to you briefly at
the beginning I remember I showed an
example with random thoughts it's
exactly the same local second model now
incorporated into into each local
circuit in a large scale system so again
the scheme looks Universal so it can
only goes a good idea and again you have
a gradient of the strengths of
excitation and inhibition right okay and
now we want to apply this model to
distributed working memory and two
papers just came out so let me just show
you one example uh you know in the model
what's useful about the composition
model I guess is to look at different
regimes so this is one example one the
local recurrent connection even in PFC
is not strong enough to sustain
Precision activity so whatever you see
should be the result of long distance
connection Loops between cortical areas
right so this is a you know assimilation
of a visual delayed response task where
you put the input V1 you should see that
V1 Mt is your strong response during
stimulus but decays away right away
right whereas lip and frontal areas show
this uh sustained activity when the
input is gone right in the lower right
you see this activity map during the
stimulus the activity is mostly in the
posterior parts of the cortex but during
the delay you see distributed working
memory that engages prevent cortex
parietal cortex and some inverter Tempo
areas if you now just you know using the
same data plot the firing rate as
function of the hierarchy for all
cortical areas then it's pretty clear
that those areas that are engaged in
working memory that involved in working
memory representation separately from
those that are not by a gap right in the
fine rate so that if you're familiar
with dynamical systems theory in the
local certain models remind you of
bifurcation diagram
except now if it is a bifurcation it's
something that it's new that I didn't
really find in the mathematical
literature because we're talking about
bifocation in space right x x axis is
the hierarchy you strongly required
networks right different areas are
talking to each other through Loops
right it's not independent you know
systems we change a parameter right and
that's not the case right so you have
this stronger Network so one prediction
about the bifurcation or phase
transition in physics is this idea that
you'll have a Divergence of time
constants the so-called critical slowing
down and indeed we find that in abstract
model right and that's that's very
interesting because as I showed you in
the resting state the time constant that
dominates Dynamics should be more or
less monotonic going up along the
hierarchy but during the delay period
the model predicts the bifurcating space
idea predicts that you actually have
this type of pattern for the time
constant when you're near the transition
the time counseling principle can go in
to Infinity right mathematically
speaking and that can be tested in
single neuron recordings so
um we also found a number of
self-certain attractive States some of
them cannot be triggered by stimulus to
a sensory area so we don't quite
understand the functional meanings of
those attractive States but you know if
you remember what I said at the
beginning I think this really is
potentially is a start right to think
about all kinds of internally driven
processes involving different subsets of
of areas
to my surprise certainly that the model
can account basically
um the you know the the results of the
meta-analysis from more than 90 among
physiological studies validating this
kind of approach at least now let me end
with one more thing which is a
how do you study distributed decision
making so we look at signal propagation
which is all the problem in
computational Neuroscience but now you
revisit it in a spike in neural version
of the model
and you give a very brief input to vui
and look at the house spikes propagate
right as shown on the left now what's
unexpected is is the plot on the right
especially if you look at the peak
response as function of the strength of
input
for prevental cortex in red there seem
to be some kind of threshold in fact
right so if you are below the threshold
basically you don't get access to BFC
there's nothing in PFC but if you are
above it you see you know that PFC
lights up right the system seems to
become a lot more active that's
reminiscent of What's called the
ignition phenomena if you heard about it
proposed by Stanis Dehan and others the
so-called Global neuronal workspace idea
for awareness so the idea is that you
know actually maybe I'll show you uh
over here so imagine that you just do a
detection task right uh this is a monkey
experiment uh using a detection task
where you just change the contrast of
visual stimulus and and below is the
psychometric function right so if you
adjust the contrast right in the middle
right near the threshold detection
threshold now with the same physical
stimulus sometimes you see sometimes you
don't see it right so in fact there are
four types of Trials right you have heat
means but also without any stimulus you
might have correct uh rejection or you
can have false alarm right what's what
this I found in this study recording
from four different areas is that in V1
and V4 neurons seem to reflect uh you
know the physical presence of stimulus
in Hit and Miss trials but in PFC the
active value is very different depending
on subjective you know awareness of the
stimulus right and so the same model
that I talked to you about actually can
reproduce essentially uh you know the
trend
um but you know across cortical areas
because we're not saying that we we have
a model for Consciousness right but we
have model for distributed working
decision making now perhaps Right
started with deduction which perhaps is
a simplest decision process but we can
start to think about more and more
complex
decision tasks
let me um maybe earned by one
speculative specificative uh slide about
abstraction right uh this is jumping you
know ahead but maybe it's appropriate
for this uh this occasion
um you know how we can really think
about really simple things gradually
towards more complex more abstract
abilities that are uniquely human right
so perhaps we can think about you know
two types of abstraction one involves
more temporal trajectories like you know
how they organize cooking a meal for
example right okay in a sequence and the
other one is more in space right you
know I'm thinking about a work like Tim
bearins and others how we can use
Stefano fuzzi right how do you think
about you know abstraction and
geometrical organization of abstraction
and maybe the combination of those two
kinds of abstractions uh really
underlying in increasingly more complex
and interesting cognitive abilities so
let me end by saying again
congratulations and and I'm sure the
center will become an icon of the field
[Applause]
thank you I think we will start with
some audience questions we have a 15
minutes q a and then I also have some
prepared uh high level big picture
questions uh if we have time
dude
there's a
yeah
thank you
you talk about autocorrelation times
um at these in these different regions
and I think that's getting at um sort of
a related question to your your sort of
starting point where you've
posited that this sort of internal life
of the Mind may be sort of generated in
these higher level areas do you have uh
data on sort of spontaneous patterns of
activity that are present outside of
stimuli in in cortices like the
prefrontal cortex that
um it may drive this this sort of
cogitation
yeah I did Show a slide of um you know
tests of this hierarchy of time
constants uh using single neural data so
people have looked at that in but
um I I think you're more asking uh if
you put the electrode in let's say
humans speech areas do you see this
internal integration process
I'm sure you know there will be those
kind of data but I'm I don't think I
think it's a start but we're just
starting to get this kind of data
that there's also just to mention that
even in simple working memory task I'm
thinking about a nice work by John
Murray uh articulating that you know
during the delay there's a manipulation
of information maybe you're doing some
logical computations converting from
here to there and that's internal
computation right and you could look at
time constants in different parts of the
brain during this process
and and yeah
with a compliment it's a beautiful talk
and and then you you have spoken of
corticocortical connectivity mainly and
the kinds of maps that one can can find
either spatial or temporal I just wonder
there are so many recurrent Loops from
down below the neocortex proper sorry to
ask but sure it they give every
appearance of being extremely powerful
and having
some of the properties that you you've
ascribed to the neocortex itself
including distributedness and modularity
yeah so you know I mentioned uh thank
you Ann for that
um that point definitely of course
subcortical structures are important
imagine that we started using this new
database from Kennedy's group of course
ideally we hope that we could use
connectivity data obtained using the
same type of measurement so it would be
uniform rather high quality data and to
manage those data are not quite
available yet Quantified you know I'm
sure you did a lot of anatomy
Susan Haber for example had a lot of
data but not quite in the same format
same kind of quantification I would love
to do that that said right you have
indeed the same kind of data for mice
right so we started to actually also
build a model for multi-regional model
of the mice brand including soft
structures actually we also started to
look at plasticity in the models it's
very exciting I think
yeah
searching yeah great talk
um so as you know there's been a lot of
work showing sequences in different
parts of the brain and cortex geologram
just recently had a really beautiful
paper showing long sequential
activations in intact Turtle brain do
you think there's a connection between
the time scale on which sequences could
persist in in these different
hierarchical areas I mean you focused on
persistent activity but sequences are a
different form of persistent activity do
you have any thoughts on on that
um not a lot so that definitely is a
very interesting open question to us
especially when you think about
multi-regional systems
um maybe just to mention that you know
Yuri Hansen I showed you one plot by his
work on human speech uh he he used the
term time integration as if it's like a
sequence right in speech you know it's a
sequence but there's no real mechanistic
kind of models uh you know at least in
this context I know of course there are
Beauty works on local circuits you know
in some birds and in parietal code hacks
either with David tank
so we start to think about this by the
way we don't really have key ideas I
mean one interesting question is that
you have this canonical circuit
organization right and then the question
is how do you endow and how do you
explain different areas that may operate
in different dynamical you know
resumes or modes right sequence versus
oscillations versus you know some other
type of dynamical regimes
so
um sorry like I was hoping that some
general questions but um yeah I mean
maybe this is partly a general question
so I'll ask it um judging I have I guess
two
Michael's question so you know there is
this hierarchy that you describe
beautifully and it was uh
um you know really interesting modeling
work on that front and so I guess
Michael's question is about you know in
as you go up the hierarchy do you see
longer and longer sequences and an
alternative question related to that is
I mean is there is that the way that we
should think about hierarchy or should
we think about hierarchy as in maybe we
should expect to see similar length
sequences or similar types of activation
in the different areas but maybe they're
representing bigger and bigger chunks of
the world and so to the point of your
plots you know you did see an increase
in time scale as you know you go up
um and you know you showed us your
computational plots where you know you
get this Divergence of time scales but
Divergence is I mean it it it's very
fine-tuned to get very long time skills
but at the same time I can think about
things on you know seconds minutes days
years decades and so where are those
that's something that's always puzzled
me where are those hierarchies like
where do we get six orders of magnitude
um do you think that's coming from the
same processes or do you think that when
we think cognitively about six orders of
magnitude in time it's something else
yeah so I'd love to talk more uh offline
maybe more but let me just quickly try
to answer your question
um I actually now I think about it maybe
just to offer my current you know take
which you know may I mean it's just take
uh is that if you really think about
sequence I want to think about two kinds
of sequences one is really like you know
Place cell kind of sequence right in
real time the other one is kind of
transitions between quasi-stable states
that's different kind of uh I think
sequence uh perhaps more relevant to
behavior or thoughts right
sorry behavioral by that I mean maybe
movements right you know a sequence of
discrete movement Primitives uh so I
don't know if you think about the first
time or the second type so about the
time constants it's more relevant for
the first type right so I mentioned the
example of predictive coding so for
example this would be a really I think
it's a good example so you know if you
try to predict
when you watch a movie you need to know
the temporal context what happened
before so that's why you need this long
time Counseling in higher areas that has
this information about the past to you
know tell the downstream system what to
expect right so that's the uh
I guess
and I guess the question I was asking is
mechanism like do you do you think I
don't really want to say sorry very long
time skills yeah so I want to really say
this this time it could go straight down
does not need any tuning no parameters
there's a special thing about the
perfection in space because if you like
it's like your parameters in space
right uh so if you change any parameters
you may move that location a bit uh but
it's it's always there
right uh I'll just take the remaining
two minute ask a general question this
is kind of unusual but can you tell us
something maybe a story about the human
side behind the science
uh you know we have lots of Junior
people here is there some like
difficulty that you and people in your
group had to overcome to do some of
these Sciences or
whoa
[Laughter]
or maybe I can give you a prompt given
that I I
so so the first let me let me actually I
don't mind that's my view yeah go ahead
so the first the first part and the
second part is is like pretty different
right so when you're starting the
research of the second part like what
are some challenges there uh is there
any challenge like you know Finding like
essentially starting a new Direction
yeah maybe I actually will start with
the first one I mean I don't mind to
tell you is that what are you asking a
bit more personal question oh yeah yeah
so how did I get into PFC right I guess
uh the long shot of it is that uh I
switched from physics to neurosciences
Robert mentioned uh in the lab of order
Freeman at Legacy Berkeley it turns out
that his father was the infamous or the
Freeman who undertook frontal lobotomies
for thousands of people including the
sister of JFK uh Rosemary Kennedy so I
got to learn about the PFC in in his lab
kind of talking and tell me about
stories and then probably I lost my job
I couldn't find you know a place to go
uh
and I went to Woods Hall to a summer
school
that was the first time that of course
took place and that's where I met John
rinzo as I was telling him I don't have
any place to go after summer school
and he facilitated helped me to find a
place in His science group and I
actually started to meet with Bob if you
remember at NIH and I started to talk to
psychiatrists that's how I got into uh
you know what the mystery of PFC uh very
accidentally
yeah thank you thank you
[Applause]